your night new hotel room and this one I
only like 30% feel like I'll be murdered
in cool hey guys it is hmm hey I said
this toasting you are nuts Grayson
undertook back to you let's set up
tumblr I bought a lottery ticket earlier
that's the kind of life I laid on the
edge I'm wasteful but hopeful and
gullible Grasser feels you person to
person to person Rome they don't know
what a new person comments over my
social media outlets I praise the crap
of them welcome to the its grace family
I don't know if it's a new piece how do
I know if it's a new person I don't know
I don't know a lot of things I just
guess and what is praising I'll let you
interpret that for yourself I guess
that's my interpretive dance it was
about love and destruction Crestor feels
more like press D seals if you get
really up-close with a seal they are
crusty and gross really cute from far
away they're like a full-on moan a
clueless movie reference I made a movie
reference and tried to get it to go all
the way over my head and face you've
been I don't have my yoga breath I
really wish I could spend a day with
these three fun and theory to spend a
day with us but we're probably good for
like a solid 20 minutes of entertainment
and then we tap out we need to sleep eat
drink be by yourself cry Whittle Goosen
crazy bars a new verse new person clues
and grace more like goose and grace
don't goose me don't touch my butt I'm
not a huge fan of it unless you're my
significant other or the old man that
worse the other day he gonna kiss me I
feel like I could have run away from him
if it got really yeah bad place yo bro
up so I wanted to cut my braces for
awhile so I finally did it I changed my
haircuts know what you like you don you
and I'm glad that you did that for
yourself because it works and in this
recession everyone's looking for a job
you tubers and many more diversity
person-to-person youtubers in many more
more like youtubers and Mandy Moore sue
is Ken day hey never look back on that
she is little and young and a little and
young and Wow I liked her and thought
she was older than me how little and
young was I Oh the youth is so
impression about here's my impression of
the youth do feel like I'm channeling
grace with my hair half professional up
top and unprofessional PJ bottoms this
is becoming a regular thing really good
really beautiful just like festive and
fun and like you get the job done and
also get eight hours of sleep
let's go Twitter yeah Lisa Jordan new
person diverse new person Lisa Jordan
more like Lisa Gibbens remember her why
is that a name in my brain what did she
do she was like a talk show host or
something and she was got people to like
talk about things and then she would try
to cry that's my recollection of her
probably entirely off she could be a
Nobel Prize winner but I think it's the
former booboo bro so thanks to gray
something I may or may not have marathon
both seasons of summer break mixing this
summer mark our departed party bathing
suit bathing suit bathing suit hormone
ho one hormone
not real gross not real growth not real
growth that summer Cal Ambrose new
person to person to person Cal Ambrose
mark cailin rosa killed ambrosia no one
likes it as a dessert why is it at why
you I really want to say grace I'm like
main town heart on tour but x0 money's
hiked got that broke swag to quote some
of my favorite talk show audience
members you're gonna cut yourself off
jaw face each other's numbers new person
ubers and Stacey Shabbos more like Cesar
Chavez I'm now just listing out random
names in my hands
yeah the day just got better I ordered
my no filter tickets for Austin huh guys
order your no filter tickets links are
down below I'm not Chuck mom stop we
need me a gun SW 13 to person to person
to person vegan SW 13 horror like ghosts
Meghan is sweet 13 that's my impression
of Siri reading your username okay I
want to drive me and a baby a 1 2 DC for
gray so makes no filter show I 100%
serious guys we're desperate
her name is money and friends that's all
they ever you on the internet and all
you need is a car and gas and a
non-creepy attitude a none harmful
persona non-threatening disposition
now it's gonna YouTube
that's my impression of every emotion
court near a new person ubers new person
Courtney may have more like Sugar Ray
what happened to goose goose is in death
camp she's been learning how to be a
good job cuz sometimes she's not this
dog get her back there soon and I'm very
excited
George earns vlogs you person to person
to person Jordans vlogs my like Jordy
very brave grace always finishes her
videos with I don't know anymore I
didn't think she doesn't know anymore
not true I and them with I don't know
and guess what truly I do not know who
does show me someone that knows
everything and I'll show you one Janet
horses [ __ ] what I look like that's
it we're talking back to you I hope that
you just had a fun time if you didn't
have fun go find something that's fun to
do my towboat just you know felt a show
pre-order Grace's guide at Great Escape
book.com Brunner Hannah Hart's book I
haven't heart that calm slash book hey
watch USA what no that was wrong almost
got all of them watch hey USA memory
nice travel show overall YouTube met
concept astronauts want a TV I just gave
you a bunch of activities that you could
do I don't mean mom will be doing this